I don't know what's wrong with this
first one I don't know
didn't sell though things that are more
exciting than Mike Pence right there
well zr nepali arms or yeah i guess so
and then right back here you got a hair
clipper yeah yeah yeah and then look at
that right there you get sewing machine
service manual and it's a whole book
filled with these so i guess i could see
why that didn't this one I don't know
check it out
pirates trying out other shoulder
accessories besides its because Betty
gold baby this guy that's nice
some sweet candies right there and then
ya bring this yeah boo not quite as
scary this one I can't believe people
didn't buy this I'd have bought this
douche babies yeah and it just these are
only douchey babies
hey goes baby oh look there's some bad
babies look at this one night you know
cuz I like ancient art and on this book
ancient drawings and wait is that
Anderson Cooper and then look here they
got more
yes and then look at this
bogie from a long time ago here's one I
guess it was for kids you know the still
going off the hold Where's Waldo thing
it's Where's Waldo x' black cousin
Courtney that's a Woody Allen premiere
right there there's a Coldplay concert
right there let's see if we can find
where are they and then finally what's
the bottom on a Conan audience let's see
can we find Courtney where is finally
dogs that just walked in on their owners
masturbator
[Applause]
lay it out
you